good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight sometimes a single
picture
so perfectly crystallizes a moment that
you want to hang in a museum as a
testament to history
dorothea lang's photographs of migrant
farm workers from the 1930s were like
that they captured the suffering of the
great depression
more powerfully than any government
report ever could
the image of the second flag raising
over iwo jima was so powerful that we
cast it in bronze
to commemorate the grit and courage of
our marines in the second world war
those images summed up entire periods of
american life
so what sums up ours what picture tells
our story well tonight we've got it for
you
decades from now our descendants will
look at this one image and know what it
was like to live in america in the year
2020.
we'll show it to you in just a second
but first some context
gavin newsom is the governor of
california our largest and for a long
time our most prosperous state
about 40 million people live in
california
so far two of them under the age of 18
have died of the covet 19 virus
so naturally gavin newsom has shut down
the entire state
businesses are shuttered people wear
masks even as they eat
large groups are forbidden to congregate
thanksgiving itself is on its way to
being cancelled
it's a tough way to live but
californians have no choice
this is science people and gavin newsom
is california's epidemiologist and chief
he commands obedience
and the serfs obey with that in mind the
san francisco chronicle broke a pretty
amazing story this week
governor newsom recently attended a
birthday dinner up in wine country at
the french laundry that's one of the
best and most expensive restaurants in
the world
there were 12 people at newsome's dinner
and to civilians
that number seemed to be a clear
violation of newsome's own rules
but as we were told it really wasn't it
turns out that newsom was simply
celebrating the birthday of a longtime
friend of his a lobbyist actually called
jason kinney a spokesperson for kinney
described the night
this way quote this was a small intimate
12-person dinner held
outdoors with family and a few close
friends to celebrate a 50th birthday
in other words no big deal for his part
governor newsome assured his suffering
subjects that quote
our family followed the restaurant's
health protocols and took
safety precautions so really ladies and
gentlemen it was nothing
just a small intimate dinner held in
nature under god's blue skies just a
few close friends staying safe and
following the protocols to the letter
letter as mandated by the state that in
fact they run
so relax people no one's getting rona
here
that was the story now the photograph we
have the picture thanks to fox 11 in los
angeles one of the rare local stations
that still does reporting
it's a picture of the birthday dinner up
in napa
it turns out it was not held outside it
was held in a private room and not a
spacious private room either
all 12 people were packed in tight
shoulder to shoulder
breathing on each other no social
distancing here
not one of them is wearing a mask a
steam room
in central wuhan could not be more
contagious than this dinner
gavin newsom's birthday party was a germ
factory and his guests were human petri
dishes
but what a guest list it was next to
governor newsom sat the
ceo of the california medical
association and won over from him
one of the state's top health lobbyists
together the two of them represent
tens of thousands of physicians
credentialed men of science
and women of science in the state of
california so if you're wondering why if
you live in california
you can't have thanksgiving this year or
visit your mother as she dies alone in
the hospital
it is because of them and people like
them and yet there they were
eating 300 truffle pasta and living like
this pandemic thing never even happened
the picture of them doing it known
henceforth to history is the
french laundry photograph is the year
2020 condensed to its essence
here you have plutocrats dining with
lobbyists
ignoring the very orders they're so
self-righteously imposing on others
gorging themselves in seclusion as the
people they're supposed to be helping
with her and die
and then when they're caught they lie
about it
how perfect is that it's all there every
element
hypocrisy greed selfishness stupidity
this is our national moment in a single
picture
move over dorothea lange
so what's gavin newsom's explanation for
this picture
well the interest of equal time and
fairness we're going to show it to you
now
i made a bad mistake instead of sitting
down
i should have stood up and
walked back got in my car and drove back
uh to
my house instead i chose to sit there
with my wife
uh and a number of other couples that
were outside the household
and you can quibble about the guidelines
et cetera et cetera but the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time uh
was contradicted and i got to own that
and so i want to apologize to you oh
yeah
when i saw it i should have just walked
out got in the car and driven home
okay gavin so you had no idea there were
going to be a dozen people
at your own party you're the governor
but you never
saw the guest list you were totally
shocked that's ridiculous
it's too stupid to be an explanation and
we are stupider for pretending to
believe it
one is tell the truth which is i don't
really totally believe
everything i say at least not enough to
let it interfere with dinner
that's the truth you know it he knows it
but he's forcing us to play along with
an absurd lie
on the other hand at least gavin newsom
didn't follow the lead of nancy pelosi
and blame the restaurant he didn't
accuse the maitre d of setting him up as
part of a conspiracy among the famously
right-wing restaurant community in napa
the french laundry probably won't suffer
the same fate as pelosi's hair stylist
at least as long as they stay quiet
about it and to his
credit gavin newsom didn't follow the
example of dianne feinstein feinstein
has refused to answer any questions as
she parades around the halls of the
united states senate
and private airport terminals fbos
maskless
and exposed breathing on people
infecting them
no explanation for that and to be fair
once again gavin newsom's explanation
though
obviously untrue is still better than
what his buddy
the lobbyist the guy they're having the
dinner for has come up with
through a spokesman he said whoa the
guest specifically requested
outdoor seating and that was provided by
the restaurant
indoor seating rather
that's what they really were doing he's
saying they were
outdoors but now we have a picture
showing that and he's still claiming it
no it was outdoors in other words ignore
the walls and the roof
what looks like inside was actually
outside
got that up is down black is white war
is peace trust me not your lying senses
if only the criminal paddle boarders had
thought of that
this spring police in california hunted
down a lone man
paddle boarding in the pacific ocean he
was off the coast of malibu
probably infecting the seals they saw
this they got them boats they alerted
the coast guard
and then sheriff's deputies put this
criminal in handcuffs
they arrested him and threatened him
with six months in prison
for breaking coronal law and the media
in california treated like was totally
normal
across the coast in california fines and
handcuffs for banned behavior
high speed pursuit one man arrested in
malibu for paddle boarding in the
pacific
while 22 sunset seekers in socal were
cited for trespassing on closed beaches
they literally put him in handcuffs for
paddle boarding alone they didn't even
claim it was a threat to marine life
they didn't even make up a pretext they
just did it
and like seals everyone applauded
so the paddle boarder gets arrested
gavin newsom gets to dine in peace
what's the lesson here you know the
lesson
if you want to live like a human being
you got to get elected to something
and then you can break your own rules
otherwise don't even think about it
here's la mayor eric garcetti explaining
how he will handle people who don't obey
this has really been marvelously
embraced by 99.9 percent of people we
see it in the traffic data
we see it in the cell phone data but
we're going to hunt down that last
one percent and say you got to get
inside you got to cut it out
and you got a distance yeah you got to
cut it out you got to get inside you got
a distance and if you don't cut it out
eric garcetti will cut your power
just like they do in china no utilities
for you corona felon
if you want to break the law if you have
it on unscratchable itch go ahead and
loot target or torch a fast food
franchise or beat up an old lady
that's federally protected political
speech but authentic human
contact no only the ruling class gets
that
so what is this exactly it's hypocrisy
of course that word's not big enough
this is
not conventional hypocrisy this is
let's stop lying an act of hostility
against the population of the country
they despise you
they're flaunting it this is how people
who don't like you
behave they force you to do one thing
they do another they get caught they're
not embarrassed and they keep forcing
you to
to do the thing they're not doing that's
an act of hostility
they don't like you last month for
example we learned that gavin newsom was
sending his own children to private
school
he made sure they could get in-person
classroom education and of course he did
they're his kids he loves them
and newsom knows what we all now know
that children don't learn
anything by remote sitting at home
on a computer screen it hurts them at
best it makes them weird
they don't learn a thing at the same
time he was sending his own children to
class in a real school
public school districts which he's in
charge of all over the state of
california remain closed because he
ordered them closed
why did he do that we never learned
there was no science he didn't bother
explain it
school children don't face a meaningful
risk from this virus
when children contract the virus cdc
data show that their survival rate is
over 99.99
and that's not a tv term in this case
it's a scientific term literally
99.99
teachers and other adults under the age
of 70 have between a 99.5
and a 99.9 chance of surviving
again not estimates real numbers from
the federal government
that's science but nobody cares about
science anymore
a few hours ago the mayor of new york
announced he was shutting down the
nation's largest school district
not because children are in peril or
suddenly becoming ill in huge numbers
they're not
de blasio did this because a rolling
seven day average of positive
chronovirus tests in new york city
went over three percent not deaths
not hospitalizations positive tests
which in the overwhelming majority of
cases
mean nothing so that's insane obviously
but it's accelerating washington's
governor jay inslee says
we're going to have to cancel christmas
but we're going to do it in the name of
love
it's just too dangerous to gather
together indoors
where the virus can spread so easily
so this year when you join us in
changing your thanksgiving and december
holiday plans
please know that you are doing it as an
act of love
an act of love says jay inslee the
politician lawyer
what a politician lawyers know about
love
not much normal people know that love is
impossible
if you're forced to live alone in
isolation
and fear now in an ideal world world
we'd all be at the french laundry
laughing and eating with our friends it
sounds wonderful especially now
sadly we can't do that we're not the
governor of anything